Oh this game has like four different
versions of Halo multiplayer you guys
have been playing it since you were you
know we lads like when you're playing
this what is the best one because you
must be like propagating towards one of
them at this stage yeah yeah I would say
so actually the first one anniversary is
like feels just real archaic and it's
actually the first time you've been able
to play it again because when it came
out it had the multiplayer worked on the
halo 4 engine oh you're right yeah yeah
oh this is the first one and that's just
real slow it's really like the way the
pistol the pistol is so so strong and so
dry three shots so floaty like I just
yeah I was not a huge fan l oh I see you
so then a halo 2 like what we're
watching it now it looks really good
there's not like that kind of barrier to
it but you know I think halo 3 is my
really honestly why I look for is is
really great but like in terms of like
what do I want to play for like a good
nostalgia fun times it's gonna be halo
is it because it's also kind of the most
modern of them like a look for its
ladies modern of them it certainly plays
more modern than halo 2 and one yeah
yeah but it also in terms of like
control really like it you know it took
me back to how it really felt like like
that game was just I was like when it
was like the first HD halo it came in
2007 and it was just oh my god it's it's
terrifying to think that halo the three
came out seven years ago absolutely nice
that was like most fully formed
multiplayer games
it was incredible made sweet Plus Forge
yeah right wait a point is for Genesis
well yes there are three versions before
actually maybe one version but you can
do it in three games because it's in
anniversaries and it's in or halo 2
anniversary Halo 3 and Halo januar but
not halo combat Evolved Anniversary
it's a lot there's a lot of ILO and it's
really interesting to think about like
what is like putting it together for
this putting this much halo together
totally germinated covenant carbines Rob
you made a bunch of features but sort of
in the lead-up to this event like you're
past the halo you've played a metric ton
of this well what's your favor so if I
were to say my favorite it would be 1 it
would be 1 now it mean it there's two
reasons why it's one one being that like
that was all we did so much land in my
garage where I lived all my life but we
played just we didn't you know we didn't
sleep we played all the time it was
really intense and what we what I really
want to play is like original blue Gulch
CTF yeah and reasons being like it was
so simple you didn't have all these
power-ups other than over shield and
cloak you just had one more power-ups
than you did - yeah yeah and that was it
but like now you just you just everyone
start off on the same playing ground and
made for such intense CTF match but like
even now like is that just nostalgia
saying that was the best time you played
like if you were to choose out of all
these right and this version that's what
are you playing tonight like oh I mean
I'd be playing halo 1 I got I got to see
if it's still the same and you know well
I'm dressed days like CTF was just so
strategic base we're like you didn't
have all these other elements it was
just simply like gangland warthog pick
up your buddy across the map and
communicating that way knowing where the
weapons spawn yes like and you Yugi
I know I played these all to like a kind
of saturation where I still have this
muscle memory of like where stuff is
I mean that's some saying it's like the
solid base is how I feel that's why I
mean what was my favorite it would still
be one but I'm just kind of playing off
like a nostalgia feel like I want I want
to try that again